hi everybody i'm jonathan trance and
today i got a really tough tactical
challenge for you guys so far only 50%
of international masters have been able
to solve it and most title players
cannot so go ahead take your time with
this one when you see it pause your
video and good luck in this position
this is white to move here you may want
to take as much time as you need here to
try to figure it out in this position i
hope you notice that black has a huge
threat the threat is queen - h1
checkmate so there's a maintenance of
the pin on the knight and the bishop so
if you played some slow move like rook
takes c6 well you might want to think
again because you're getting checkmated
so you're going to have to try to find
the most forceful moves in this position
that is a big hint so if you haven't
looked at all the forcing moves as many
as you can even if they look kind of
ludicrous at first go ahead and have a
look at them and maybe that will help
you solve this puzzle the most forceful
move you have in this position is rook
g7 okay so black just takes back what's
the problem here
well now we take the bishop with our
rook again another forceful move ok
Knight takes g7 what's the problem what
does y do now hopefully you're looking
at the most forceful move again Queen
takes g7 ok so the King takes our Queen
again we must play with as much force as
possible Bishop takes f8 ok the King
takes back and now hopefully we see the
main idea Knight takes h3 trapping the
Queen on the Kings side and white with
his extra pass pawns
should go on to win this endgame
thank you everybody for watching this
video I know that was a super hard one
so a huge congrats to anybody that was
able to get that one right as always hit
like share subscribe we'll see you next
time for another tactical challenge